♪ ♪
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TAKING ON
PRACTICALLY ALL COMERS TONIGHT
VIA KEYBOARD.
HE RALLIED AGAINST NO PARTICULAR
ORDER, THE LATE
SENATOR JOHN McCAIN,
JOE BIDEN, THE MULLER
INVESTIGATION, EVEN SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE.
THE PRESIDENT IS PARTICULARLY
UPSET AT CRITICS WHO HE SAYS ARE
BLAMING HIM FOR A WHITE
NATIONALIST TERROR ATTACK AND
NEW ZEALAND.
IT IS ON THAT SUBJECT THAT WE
BEGIN TONIGHT WITH JOHN ROBERTS.
LIVE ON THE NORTH LONG.
>> HE REALLY HAS BEEN USING
TWITTER OR SOMETHING OF A
GATLING LATELY WITH THE
60 MILLION FOLLOWERS.
ONE PRESIDENTIAL TWEET GOES AN
AWFUL LONG WAY AND AS YOU SAID,
HE HAS BEEN PRETTY PROLIFIC OVER
THE LAST FEW DAYS.
THERE'S ONE THING IN PARTICULAR
THAT HAS HIS ATTENTION.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ON
DEFENSE TODAY LASHING OUT
AGAINST CRITICS WHO SUGGESTED A
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND THE NEW ZEALAND KILLER
QUOTING "THE NEWS MEDIA IS
WORKING OVERTIME TO BLAME ME FOR
THE HORRIBLE ATTACK AND
NEW ZEALAND.
THEY WILL HAVE TO WORK HARD TO
PROVE THAT ONE.
SO RIDICULOUS."
THE COLLECTED MENTION
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I HATE FIELD
SCREEN THAT HE POSTED ONLINE
HAIL AND THE PRESIDENT AS A
SYMBOL OF RENEWED WHITE IDENTITY
AND COMMON PURPOSE.
>> HE IS NOT A WHITE SUPREMACIS
SUPREMACIST.
>> CHRIS WALLACE ACTING CHIEF OF
STAFF AT MICK MULVANEY HAD TO MY
CAT'S BOSS IS BACK PROJECTING
ANY COMMON GROUND BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT ON THE KILLING ON
IMMIGRATION
>> THAT IT'S ABSURD TO SAY THERE
IS SOME TYPE OF CONNECTION
BETWEEN BEING AGAINST ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION WHICH IS WHAT DEVITO
IS ABOUT.
THE RUTHLESS LIVE STREAMING OF
MURDERING 15 PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
EACH OTHER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD A
PARTICULARLY ACTIVE WEEKEND
FIRING UP 29 FEET TO MY TWEETS
AND TAKING A SHOT AT
JOHN McCAIN WHO LEFT IN HIS
CLASS FOR SENDING THE FAKE
DOSSIER FOR THE FBI AND WEEDY
HOPING TO HAVE IT PRINTED BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
IN DEMOCRATS WORKING TOGETHER
FELT AS USUAL.
HE FIRED BACK, FIRST ON TWITTER
AND THEN THIS MORNING ON ABC.
>> HE IS OBSESSING OVER GREAT
MAN BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT AND I
KNOW IT, HE WILL NEVER BE A
GREAT MAN.
>> HE ALSO TOOK AIM AT
GENERAL MOTORS OVER THE OHIO
PLANT CLOSING DEMANDING CEO SELL
IT OR DO SOMETHING QUICKLY.
SHE BLAMED THE UAW UNION.
DAVID GREEN WAS SINGLED OUT FOR
SAYING SOME TRUMP SUPPORTER'S
MAY BE HAVING SECOND THOUGHTS
ABOUT HIM AFTER SEVERAL BIG
CLOSURES IN OHIO.
>> SOME FOLKS I KNOW HAVE
SWITCHED GEARS.
WHEN HE CAME HERE IS THAT ALL
THESE GREAT THINGS AND THEY WERE
ON BOARD WITH THAT.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO WAKE UP.
>> THE PRESIDENT RIPPED FOX NEWS
WHERE GRAIN WAS APPEARING.
WITH THE MOLAR REPORT EXPECTED
AT ANY MOMENT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HIGHLIGHTED A USA TODAY PULLED
AT 550% OF AMERICANS ARE GREAT
THAT ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION AS A WITCH HUNT.
VERY FEW THINK IT IS LEGIT.
WE WILL SOON FIND OUT.
THERE ARE NEW QUESTIONS WHETHER
THE REPORT WILL ADD TO THE MOLAR
INVESTIGATION, PARTICULARLY
SINCE ROBERT MUELLER HAS ASKED
TO RELATE RICK GATES SENTENCING
WILL HE CONTINUES TO COOPERATE
WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE.
U.S. ATTORNEY BELIEVES THERE MAY
BE MORE ADDED.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD BE WITH SOME
SKEPTICISM.
THE NOTION THAT HAS BREATHLESSLY
REPORTED, THE INVESTIGATION IS
COMING TO AN END.
>> HE DID SAY THAT IT ALSO IS
POSSIBLE THAT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE COULD BE
SHUTTERED IF LIKE MICHAEL: THE
INVESTIGATION SURROUNDING RICK
GATES HAS HANDED OFF TO OTHER
DISTRICTS.